IT TOOK 12 BALLOTS BUT NOW A
BREAK IN THE REPUBLICAN
RESISTANCE, McCARTHY PROMISED
PROGRESS.
WE ARE SEEING IT.
14 REBEL HOLD-OUTS MOVING FROM
NEVER TO EVENTUALLY KEVIN FOR
THE FIRST TIME McCARTHY NETTING
MORE VOTES THAN HAKEEM JEFFRIES.
WE SHOULD NOTE McCARTHY STILL ON
TRACK TO FALL SHORT OF THAT
MAGIC NUMBER NEEDED TO CLINCH
THE SPEAKERSHIP.
WE SHALL SEE.
IT'S LIKELY THEY'LL MOVE QUICKLY
TO ANOTHER VOTE.
TO MANU RAJU ON CAPITOL HILL.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING AND HEARING.
>> Reporter: THERE'S GOING TO BE
A REAL EFFORT TO WIN OVER THOSE
REMAINING HOLD-OUTS.
PATRICK McHENRY ONE OF THE TOP
DEPUTIES OF KEVIN McCARTHY TOLD
ME MOMENTS AGO THEY SEE CLEAR
MOMENTUM MOVING IN THEIR
DIRECTION.
NOW THEY'LL FOCUS ON THOSE
REMAINING HOLD-OUTS AND MAY HAVE
SUPPORT FROM SOME OF THOSE THAT
FLIPPED.
SCOTT PERRY THE LEAD OF THE HARD
RIGHT HEIGHT FREEDOM CAUCUS
OPPOSING KEVIN McCARTHY ALL
ALONG BUT ENGAGED IN
NEGOTIATIONS OVER THE LAST DAY
OR SO TO GIVE THEM MORE SAY OVER
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SAYING
THE DEAL WAS INKED AND SAID HE
WAS COMFORTABLE WITH IT AND
DECIDED TO MOVE FORWARD.
HE JUST TOLD A GROUP OF US JUST
NOW THEY PLAN TO LOBBY AND
DISCUSS AND TRY TO CONVINCE SOME
OF THE MEMBERS WHO MAY BE
HESITANT TO SUPPORT THIS RIGHT
NOW.
NOW, ALSO ONE VERY IMPORTANT
THING HE SAID THAT WAS PART OF
THE DEAL IS DEALING WITH RAISING
THE NATIONAL DEBT LIMIT.
HE JUST TOLD A GROUP OF US THEY
ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A MAJOR,
MAJOR FLASH POINT IN THE NEW
CONGRESS.
THEY HAVE TO AVOID A DEBT
DEFAULT.
THAT WILL HAPPEN SOMETIME THIS
YEAR, MAYBE THE MIDDLE PART OF
THIS YEAR.
ONE THING HE SAID THEY WOULD NOT
AGREED TO A CLEAN DEBT CEILING
INCREASE.
THEY NEED CONDITIONS TIED TO
AVOID A NATIONAL DEBT DEFAULT
WHICH HAS NEVER HAPPENED IN
AMERICAN HISTORY SO THAT IS
GOING TO BE A HUGE FIGHT GOING
FORWARD.
BUT FROM WHAT SCOTT PERRY TOLD A
GROUP OF US THAT WAS PART OF
THIS DEAL THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
PUBLICLY RELEASED BUT APPARENTLY
WAS REACHED BETWEEN A HANDFUL OF
HOLD-OUTS AND KEVIN McCARTHY.
SO THIS DEAL NOT JUST PROCESS,
GIVING THEM MORE LEVERAGE OVER
THE SPEAKER, BEING ABLE TO OUST
A SITTING SPEAKER WITH ONE
INDIVIDUAL DOING THAT, HAVING
MORE MEMBERS OF THOSE HARD-RIGHT
FREEDOM CAUCUS BUT POLICY
IMPLICATIONS DEALING WITH THE
DEBT CEILING.
BIG SIGNIFICANT ISSUE GOING
FORWARD BUT FOR McCARTHY RIGHT
NOW ON THE FLOOR THEY'RE
COUNTING THE VOTES RIGHT NOW.
THE CLERKS ARE MAKING SURE THAT
THE TALLY IS CORRECT.
HE'S GOING TO LIKELY FALL SHORT
HERE BUT THEY FEEL CLEAR
MOMENTUM.
THEY THINK THEY CAN GET THERE
MAYBE NOT TODAY BUT VERY CLOSE,
MAYBE IN THE NEXT COMING DAYS
THEY BELIEVE THAT McCARTHY WILL
SOON BECOME SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
>> MANU, DO YOU EXPECT THEM TO
PUSH FOR ANOTHER VOTE
IMMEDIATELY?
>> Reporter: THAT WAS THE
EXPECTATION.
WHEN I ASKED PATRICK McHENRY
ABOUT THAT DO YOU EXPECT ANOTHER
VOTE AFTER THIS ONE, HE SAID, I
DO.
THAT WAS THE EXPECTATION GOING
IN.
NOW THEY, OF COURSE, NEED TO
HAVE ALL 218 MEMBERS, 218 VOTES
TO ADJOURN THE HOUSE.
UNCLEAR IF THEY WOULD HAVE THAT
AND TAKE A BREAK TO NEGOTIATE
FURTHER OFFLINE.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE 218 TO
ADJOURN THEY'RE REQUIRED TO GO
TO ANOTHER SPEAKER VOTE AND C
COULD SEE THAT AFTER THIS.
THESE NEGOTIATIONS PROBABLY ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN AS THESE VOTES
WRAP UP BEHIND THE SCENE IN THE
CLOAKROOM AND IN OFFICE JUST OFF
THE HOUSE FLOOR.
McCARTHY HAS BEEN OCCUPYING IT
AS THEY TRY TO NAIL DOWN THE
FINAL VOTES AND FINALLY CLAIM
THE SPEAKERSHIP, ANDERSON.
>> THANKS.
WE'LL CHECK BACK IN WITH YOU.
BACK IN NEW YORK, SCOTT PERRY
OBVIOUSLY A BIG -- AS THE LEADER
OF THE FREEDOM CAUCUS, THAT IS A
BIG SWITCH.
>> I THINK SCOTT PERRY IS BIG,
CHIP ROY, SOME OF -- BYRON
DONALDS, GOSAR, ALL OF THESE ARE
BIG GET, NORMAN AND I THINK THE
DIFFERENCE IS NOW OTHER THAN
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE KEVIN
McCARTHY AND HIS LIEUTENANTS
GOING AROUND TWISTING ARMS.
YOU'LL HAVE THESE 14 PEOPLE WHO
JUST SWITCHED TWISTING THE ARMS
OF THE OUTLIERS OF THE THOSE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL SAY WE DID
THIS.
WE NEED YOU TO COME ALONG AND
MAKE THE ARGUMENT.
SCOTT PERRY IS GOING TO MAKE THE
ARGUMENT.
>> YOU KNOW, THE QUESTION -- I
MEAN, THEY DIDN'T COME ALONG
BECAUSE THEY HAD SOME SORT OF
ENLIGHTENMENT.
THEY CAME ALONG BECAUSE THEY CUT
DEALS.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT ADDITIONAL
DEALS DID THEY HAVE TO CUT WITH
THE REMAINING AND ARE THEY
SUBJECT TO CUTTING DEALS OR ARE
THEY JUST MORE -- BUT, YOU KNOW,
THIS THING THAT MANU TALKED
ABOUT, THE DEBT CEILING, THIS
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE WORRIED ABOUT.
I WAS AROUND IN 2011 WHEN THERE
WAS THE -- THERE WAS A SIMILAR
EFFORT TO TRY AND, YOU KNOW, TIE
THE DEBT CEILING TO ALL KINDS OF
CONCESSIONS, AND, YOU KNOW, IT
TOOK US TO THE PEST 'TIS OF WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A CATASTROPHE
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THIS IS WHY I
UNDERSTAND THE SORT OF SPORT OF
ALL OF THIS, BUT THE AFTERMATH
IS GOING TO BE VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THESE
SEVEN HOLD-OUTS HAVE CLAIMED
THEY WANT IS DEEP INVESTIGATIONS
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE THE MOST INTERESTED IN
GETTING THE INVESTIGATORY
PROCESS ROLLING.
WHAT I EXPECT TO HAPPEN ON THE
FLOOR NEXT IS FOR THE CLERK TO
READ THE TALLY, THEM ROLL INTO
ANOTHER VOTE AND I THINK THE
NEXT NOMINATING SPEECH FOR
McCARTHY IS GOING TO BE GIVEN BY
CONGRESSMAN JAMIE COMER OF
KENTUCKY'S FIRST DISTRICT.
HE WILL BE ONE OF THE MOST
FAMOUS MEMBERS BECAUSE HE WILL
BE THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND BE THE
TIP OF THE SPEAR AN ALL THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
HERE'S WHAT'S TRUE.
AS LONG AS THIS IS GOING ON,
THAT COMMITTEE DOESN'T EXIST AND
THE OVERSIGHT DOESN'T EXIST AND
THE SUBPOENAS DON'T EXIST, BUT
BECAUSE COMER IS GETTING UP TO
MAKE A SPEECH HERE I JUST THINK
IT BEARS POINTING OUT.
IF YOU VOTED FOR A REPUBLICAN
FOR THE HOUSE AND ARE A
CONSERVATIVE THERE'S PROBABLY
100% CHANCE YOU WANT BIDEN TO BE
INVESTIGATED AND THE MATT GAETZ
SEVEN ARE STOPPING YOU AND I
HOPE JAMIE COMER MAKES THAT
POINT IN THE SPEECH.
>> WHO HAS BEEN MAKING THE
POINT, SOMEONE LIKELY TO BE A
NEW MEMBER IF REPORTS ARE
CORRECT, MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
WHO IS ON NO COMMITTEES BECAUSE
OF HER BEHAVIOR AND SHE WROTE
TODAY, DEMS ARE OPENLY PLOTTING
TO ELECT A MODERATE DEMOCRAT
APPROVED SPEAKER IF WE DON'T
ELECT McCARTHY.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN WARNING
ABOUT.
IF THAT HAPPENS YOU CAN KISS
INVESTIGATIONS GOOD-BYE.
CRIME FAMILY, WEAPONIZATION AND
SUBPOENA POWER GOOD-BYE.
WELCOME TO THE NEW ERA.
>> DID YOU RETWEET THAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> IN TERMS OF GRINDING THESE
PEOPLE DOWN, I'M JUST TELLING
YOU, ALL THESE GRASSROOTS DONOR,
ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO KNOCK ON
DOORS, THE FACT THAT THEY SHOULD
NOW KNOW RIGHT NOW THE ONLY
THING STANDING BETWEEN
INVESTIGATING BIDEN AND
SUBPOENAING MAYORKASS AND
LOOKING INTO THE BORDER,
WHATEVER.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
DO YOU THINK LAST NOVEMBER --
>> 2243241 --
>> WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN
NOVEMBER.
WE ALL SAW WHAT HAPPENED.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS WHAT THE
BROADER ELECTORATE IS HUNGERING
FOR, I CAN'T WAIT TO GET THE
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON?
>> NO, THAT'S --
>> NO, BUT --
>> I'M MAKING A DIFFERENT POINT
WHICH IS THERE'S THIS NARROW
THING AS TO WHETHER KEVIN
McCARTHY CAN PIECE THE VOTES
TOGETHER TO BE SPEAKER AND THEN
THERE'S THIS LARGER THING, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN FOR THE REST OF
THE TWO YEARS OF HIS TENURE?
I SUSPECT IT WILL ONLY BE TWO
YEARS IF IT IS TWO YEARS AND
THIS IS WHAT WE CAN LOOK FORWARD
TO.
>> YOUR POINT ABOUT THE DEBT
CEILING, THOSE NEGOTIATIONS ARE
NEVER EASY.
POINT TO 2011.
ALWAYS A TENSION BETWEEN, YOU
KNOW, WE CONTINUE TO SPEND
CRAZILY, RIGHT, MONEY WE DON'T
HAVE, RAISE TAX, HOW DO WE DO
THIS?
A LOT THINK THERE ARE BUDGET
DEFICITS RUNNING OUT OF CONTROL
AND TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THAT'S A CONCERN ALWAYS NOT JUST
IN THIS CONGRESS SO I DON'T
KNOW.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY I THINK WE
HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES AFTER WHAT
WE'VE SEEN, THE DEBT CEILING,
AGAIN, IT WOULD BE A
CATASTROPHE.
YOU HAVE SEVEN PEOPLE, WE HAD
20, MAYBE 10, NOW 7 WHO ARE
WILLING TO TAKE US TO THE BRINK
FOR THREE DAYS, THERE IS A VERY
REAL QUESTION THAT DAVID IS
PUTTING ON THE TABLE IN TERMS OF
WHAT IS ACTUALLY IN THIS DEAL
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE AT
LEAST SEVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE
PERFECTLY WILLING TO TAKE US
TO -- DAVID, LET ME FINISH, WHO
ARE PERFECTLY WILLING TO LET US
GO TO THE VERY BRINK OF
DESTRUCTION, AGAIN, AS YOU SAID,
ONLY FOR THEIR OWN GAIN.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK WE ARE
ON THE BRINK OF DESTRUCTION AND
CATASTROPHE WITH THE DEBT LIMIT
SPENDING, RUNAWAY SPENDING AND
CONTINUE TO RAISE THE DEBT
CEILING.
>> THEY DIDN'T THINK THAT DURING
FOUR YEARS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HE ADDED MORE THAN ANYBODY.
>> I'M NOT ARGUING.
THERE IS A CONTINGENT HERE IN
AMERICA THAT FINDS THAT EQUALLY
REPUGNANT AS RAISING THE DEBT
CEILING.
>> HOW LIKELY IS IT IN THE NEXT
ROUND ASSUMING THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO VOTE, IS THERE
ENOUGH TIME TO MOVE SOME OF
THESE SEVEN WHO REMAIN?
>> THERE MIGHT BE.
THERE MIGHT BE.
LOOK, THERE'S SEVEN AND IT LOOKS
LIKE HE'S GOING TO NEED TO FLIP
AT LEAST THREE.
IF HE CAN FLIP THREE OF THE
SEVEN THEN HE CAN GET IT TODAY.
LOOKING AT WHO THOSE PEOPLE ARE,
LAUREN BOEBERT DOESN'T SEEM
FLIPABLE.
MATT GAETZ NOT FLIPABLE.
ANDY BIGGS, ROSENDALE, HARRISON
CRANE MAYBE.
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE A REAL
TEST OF KEVIN McCARTHY AND
FRANKLY HIS ABILITY TO ENROLL
HIS ALLIES IN AN EFFORT TO
CHANGE SOME OF THESE HOLD-OUTS.